[موسيقى]
كان هناك مريض تحت الرعاية
القلب الذي استعاد المنصب
العلاج عليه لحسن الحظ من قبل أ
المشيئة الإلهية
لقد نجا ولكن لا هو في حالة جيدة
صحة
من جانبنا كنا قادرين
إعادة بناء وإعادة تأهيل هذا
غرفة كما قمنا بإعادة تأهيل الجميع
وحدة رعاية الحي
[موسيقى]
بفضل المانحين من القطاع الخاص
تمكنا من تخفيضات الجهات المانحة
استئناف إعادة إعمار
المستشفى لدينا محافظ في تشيلي
حوالي 80٪ من إعادة الإعمار
[موسيقى]
هذه هي مساحة الطوارئ لدينا مرحبا
مرحبا اليوم مشكلتك
حاليا لم يعد ملف
مشكلة هيكلية في الوقت الحالي
ماذا نفعل في مواجهة الأزمات
اقتصادي
رحيل مقدمي الرعاية الحليب
الممرضة ونقص الأدوية
وربما أيضا عدم وجود
وقود النفط والكهرباء اللوجستية
تيار الصحراء للعمل
المستشفى
المشكلة هي أننا نشعر بالفعل
نحن غير قادرين على بيع مرضانا
حالياً
عندما أتلقى مكالمة و
لا يمكنني إيجاد حل ل
حارة الشر هو حقا صعب جدا
نفسيا
[موسيقى]
حرفيا راتبي حتى 60 إلى 65
بالدولار في الشهر بينما قبل
الأزمة كانوا بين 800 و 900 بذلك
نفعل ما يتعين علينا القيام به ولكن في النهاية لدينا
يكفي بالكاد للبقاء على قيد الحياة في
البلد الذي يعوقه الفساد
نقص وسائل نقص الدخل
لا يمكنني الحصول على هذا هنا لا أستطيع
ليس لديك الاستقرار الكافي لذلك نعم
بصراحة أعتقد أنني سأغادر
الآن قادم هذا شيء آخر
سؤال آمل في المستقبل أن
سيكون الوضع أفضل بكثير لأن
هذا في النهاية هو الشخص والقضيب
و
[موسيقى]